In this video, we'll go over some of the tessellation options available when importing
CAD files into Unreal Engine.
If you're working from CAD or computer-aided design programs, we should talk about the
tessellation options available to you.
These are for NURBS services only.
NURBS of course stands for Non-Uniform Rational Beast Splines and are often extremely curvy
geometry that is generated in a different way from traditional meshes with polygons
and triangles.
Because Unreal Engine does not support NURBS directly, we'll have to tessellate and triangulate
NURBS as they come into Unreal Engine.
Essentially, we'll need to determine how the bodies and the surfaces will be processed,
and then we'll be creating a static mesh, which is Unreal Engine's file type used as
a base for further processing.
Here you'll want to ensure you have enough detail for your targeted applications, not
so much that you end up overburdening your system in getting a frame rate loss, but also
not so little that we're not seeing the appropriate level of geometry detail necessary.
This will be dependent on the individual model elements.
Here in the Datasmith Import options, we have a few things we can change here.
We can talk about the tolerance, the edge length.
We'll discuss each of these in the following slides.
So let's take a closer look at tessellation and how we process the converting of 3D precise
surfaces defined by algorithms and vectors into meshes.
The three primary settings we'll be investigating are Cord Tolerance, Max Edge Length, and
Normal Tolerance.
Cord Tolerance defines the distance between the reference cat surface and the resulting
triangular surface in UE5.
Meshes do not actually have curves in their geometry, everything has to get straightened
out at some point, so this is one of the first instances where we decide where something
becomes straight that otherwise should be curved.
If we take a look at the seat, we have references of 0.1mm Cord Tolerance, 0.5mm Cord Tolerance,
and 10mm Cord Tolerance, which as we can see creates progressively more triangles if we
have a smaller Cord Tolerance.
And we'll see this as a bit of a pattern.
The smaller we make these numbers for tolerance, the higher our triangle count will be.
Now, are any of these correct?
It depends entirely on your application and how important this particular seat is.
If you are doing a driving simulator and it needs to run on a mobile phone and you're
spending a lot of time close to the seat, you probably want the seat to be pretty high
quality but you're going to be limited by the processing power of the phone.
If you have a seat that is going to be far away and it's not an important part of your
scene and you're on a very heavy PC, maybe in that case you might actually use an even
smaller triangle count than what you'd be using on a phone, it all depends on the priority
you want to give it and what kind of frames per second you're willing to sacrifice.
This will also give us a sense of harder edges or softer edges.
Maximum edge length defines the maximum length of any edge in the triangle.
Looking at our seat example again, we can see that as the number is lower, 10mm versus
20 versus 40, the lower number has the highest number of triangles and we can see in the
wire frame the density of that versus the higher tolerance of 40mm which only produces
21,000 triangles.
Now we have a few different ways that we can get into fine tuning exactly how this is set
up.
We have various CVARS and I'll give you a few examples of them when we do the exercise
but ds4datasmith.cadtranslator.disableCADCURNALTESCELATION0 is a way that we can actually start to affect
this setting more directly.
It's on by default and needs to be deactivated in order to use CADCURNALTESCELATION0.
And once more here with normal tolerance we see how this defines the maximum angle between
adjacent triangles and using our seat example we can see 5 degrees versus 10 degrees versus
40 degrees with the larger tolerance resulting in fewer triangles and a smaller tolerance
resulting in more triangles because it is trying to be more accurate with how the curvilinear
surfaces get translated into meshes.
Once again what makes the most sense for your project will be application specific.
And of course don't forget that you can also set up LODs or Nanite which we'll talk about
later on which allow us to have various levels of detail when we're closer or farther away
from the object.
Now let's do a short exercise where we import a CAD file into Unreal Engine and retestulate
the components to add additional detail.
Over in Unreal Engine 5.6 I'm going to open my content drawer and in a folder I will import
a CAD model in CAD files, CATIA, TurboCharger, Darshart, and Kibar.
We have one here called assembly matap.catproduct, catproduct file.
And if we go ahead and open this up you'll see that we will not be presented with an
import dialog box, it will import on its own and we have static meshes here as well as
a simple white material.
So we go ahead and open up hybrid body 1.
We can hover over it for a moment and see some details of it.
And we can see here that we've got 3,640 triangles and so our goal is to increase that.
We can see a little bit of some hard edges here, right?
So let's see if we can make those feel a little softer.
This is a hero object that we're going to be inspecting very closely inside our Unreal
Engine application.
Now I do want to note that we have reimport mesh with dialog and this normally would be
a great way to do what we want to do.
It does not work in this case but fear not, we do have the ability to retesolate by right
clicking on the object here and choosing retesolate.
Now keeping an eye on this again, 3,640 we can start to bring these numbers down as we
saw in our previous examples if we want to bring the triangle count up.
So let's try .1 for chord tolerance and let's try making the normal tolerance 10 degrees
instead of 20.
We'll leave these options as they are, leave max edge length at zero and go ahead and hit
tessellate.
And there we go.
We see it goes up to 11,446 and now these are much softer edges.
We could continue to bring it up further if we wanted to and if we wanted to remove some
of those dark shadows for Nanite we could either disable Nanite or go ahead and uncheck
support ray tracing.
Lastly just to give you a little preview of some of the Datasmith CAD translator C-Vars
we have access to, there's quite a few of them and if you want to know about any of
these in particular you can just click on them and then just add a question mark to
the end and open that up in the output log, scroll down to the bottom here and we can
see there it says disable to use the CAD import library tessellator.
The default is that it's enabled so once again we could add zero to disable it.
In the next video we'll go even deeper into understanding triangle count.